[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
dude to turn down 400 million you just
don't like the city
for [ __ ] 10 years so there's this
baseball player Brian his name is
yeah
he plays for Washington he's you know
probably the best player in the league
right now he's he's like he's like a
Phenom yeah yes so Washington goes well
we don't want you going anywhere we're
going to give you the max deal so
whatever it was like it was like 10
years 400 million something almost 500.
so much money 400 million 400 million to
keep him there for the rest of his
career
excuse me he said no he said no he and
the time and the Padres got him
yesterday he went to San Diego did he
really
yeah around this Max yeah like you know
he was just like no I'm good because he
he knew though and he didn't know he was
getting oh he's so good yeah he knew
that he was going to get them I'll just
go I'll take my skills to [ __ ]
San Diego yeah look Washington
our boy big George Tito George it's Mark
Harley's birthday
happy birthday to you it's your birthday
to you
yeah that's a nice looking cake wow that
is a really nice looking cake and I was
going to say uh
the two is on there because I'm doing
two podcasts today you know and I'm just
on the phone to say hey can't talk right
now super busy day school podcasting I
never stop I just I can't stop won't
stop that cake looks like it's made of
mud I'm gonna be honest with it yeah you
don't look a day over 19. you're like
19. you look like the two-year-old in
the history
thank you I appreciate it guys you've uh
you know I don't expect much from anyone
Brendan and you guys have made it a very
fun very memorable birthday of course
brother happy birthday couldn't couldn't
be happier to be here so go and eat
something
the thick boy team also got Mark you
know because Mark does like to splurge
when he's not on his diet they got him I
don't know 10 pounds of McDonald's
breakfast it was awesome really I didn't
eat all of it yet but just knowing that
it's there and having one of the
sandwiches so far has been amazing all
right all right now your birthday wasn't
as good as Juan Soto's
MLB's first 500 million dollar deal he's
just one of the he's got all the tools
he's got all the tools yeah you know
he's just one of those guys that's just
I didn't know they signed this just
happened five hours ago God you're up on
it appreciate it I thought it was
yesterday
that's half a billion dollars uh that's
half a billion Padres dollars it's half
a billion
and I didn't know it's gonna sound
stupid but I didn't know that there was
a big enough audience I thought the
attendance on baseball they don't care
about tenants baseball's not about 10.
TV TV I think baseball in this weird way
this year is coming back slightly I
agree and I took my son to Yankee
Stadium the other night uh we I did a
[ __ ] on the whim like my my wife and
daughter were going out to and she was
taking a look at my Lucas's 13th and
Sophia's 10. so she goes uh me and
Sophia are going to you know Frances
gonna go swimming she wants to take
Lucas to dinner so I go in his room and
I just five o'clock okay I go you wanna
play video games buddy what do you want
to do and he just goes uh I don't know
yeah maybe and I go [ __ ] that yeah but
you wanna go to the stadium yeah and I
go stay so I'm gonna take him to Yankee
Stadium she goes because I do [ __ ] like
she's really pull Tuesday night I go
[ __ ] and I go we're getting good seats
so we get low low seats go down they
play Cincinnati Reds great time 80
degrees no humidity I'm got a beer with
my son we went in the bottom of it
nothing better we win in the bottom walk
it was a it was a wild thing no it was a
walk while we had a runner on third wow
pitch come home place goes nuts go home
you know our you know 20 with the
memories for your son though I remember
when my dad when he was like a school
night and we'd do something cool I mean
we didn't go to Yankee Stadium back then
but you're gonna have money but it was
like even just go to the mall and you
guess like all the pizza because they
were throwing it out and he paid like
ten dollars to get like 10 pizzas yeah
it was a great those memories I don't
forget isn't it funny like my kids like
they don't get it man no get their feet
up on that in in lexuses you gotta she
got it but I saw a picture of you and
you're kidding it's like I grew up in a
[ __ ] my parents had those old wagons
you know and it was just a jalopy it was
like orange it was always [ __ ] up and
we'd go out to eat maybe once a month
and it would be like a shitty yeah now
my son my son wanted to go fishing in
Panama
watches that he wanted to go fishing in
Panama he's like Dad can we go to France
for a weekend it's like I'm like you
guys don't understand no they don't and
listen me and my wife made the choice to
give we want that but at the same time
it's like you got to kind of understand
what's happening here well I think I
think of you if you you give your kids
experiences no matter what like
experiences so if they go to France they
go to Panama that's a [ __ ] experience
that's worth paying for but yeah you let
them know it's still yeah still flying
first class and [ __ ] you're like let
them know I just like first class I was
30 little bastard also yeah linked up my
same thing my uh my buddy our boy Kevin
B called me I told you a story Brian my
buddy Kevin Bay who he works with all
the All-Star pitchers and stuff yeah he
goes hey man uh the All-Star games in LA
and this is Day of the All-Star Game I
know it is he goes yeah I have two uh uh
tickets in the suite you want to go I'm
like and this was at like three o'clock
on Monday and he's supposed to have Jiu
Jitsu and I'm like you know what [ __ ] it
was the Home Run Derby like you you can
be more excited yeah dude we get there
we're in the Dodger Suite bro the Dodger
the owner of the doc next to me is Kevin
Durant to the left is back with Johnson
we're there and he's he's chicken
tenders and the free food and all this
[ __ ] and I can see I was looking at his
home run derby I was a little bored
myself and uh after four batters and I
see him just staring at the ground and
now before this let me play division
before this he wanted merch that's why
he likes the Jersey a lot yeah yeah
we'll get the merch at the stadium they
only sell the authentic one so I get
myself a Dodgers All-Star I get the kids
one yeah they're like 800 ago
um no no no no no he's the kid she goes
honey you're you're at the this is all
we have is the authentic ones even the
kids I'm like this is it she was yeah
another one you know embarrassed my son
like I'll take them I'm like
[ __ ] and in my head I'm like
well I didn't pay for the ticket so this
is even out right yeah so we sit down I
can tell he's bored and he's staring at
the ground and I go hey what the [ __ ]
what's wrong with you yeah he goes uh
how much longer oh my God
when did the Dodgers come out bro I've
been over this and now I'm just in a bad
mood like we just went over this dude
it's a home run derby they're hitting
home runs that's all you go to baseball
games for there could be nothing better
and I go dude look around you these are
the best seats in the house yeah and he
looks over the railing with the front
row of the sweet oh my God he looks over
and goes those are the best ones aren't
they oh my God and I
dude they're in the sun they don't have
their own bathroom and they got to look
we're like we got banished seriously
yeah and I go also I go I go I go look
around you dude I know who this is for
me I'm trying to be quiet you know who
that is
It's Magic Johnson one of the greatest
basketball players of all time he owns
the Dodgers he could sit anywhere he
wants he's here next to us are you know
who that is are you like this I see
Kevin Durant look at me here
that's true dad's favorite basketball
player that is the best basketball
player on [ __ ] or teams and he has
more money than anybody you know do you
talk to him or no Durant yeah and I go
he can see anybody anywhere he wants
he's in he's in our sweet dude yeah
instead quite after that right he goes
that's not LeBron James oh my god dude
[Laughter]
I I pretended you know what I do unless
I pretend it never happened I just
stared at the sky went oh [ __ ] yeah did
you talk to Kevin Grant yeah Durant yeah
yeah I mean just for a second yeah I do
apologize hey man he likes you he's
joking
he doesn't even like LeBron I told him
to say I was [ __ ] with you loud
enough yeah they don't I'm thinking I'm
gonna strike him dude and he had
LeBron's shoes on we uh I so I do I do
that's hilarious I do um I do a firework
show and on Fourth of July and and it
and I go really [ __ ] big okay and it
means a lot to me to have people come up
I mean I'm talking big is it legal no no
no okay so so it's it's no I mean I had
an Italian friend drive up dude I had
[ __ ] that comes off to Macy's barge in
my next to my neighbor's house my
neighbor's roof looked like a [ __ ]
Jet Jet Blue fuselage blew up over his
house I swear to God he was real pissed
he threatened me with a gun actually he
says my wife's been out here cleaning do
like debris everywhere so I go real big
big like and everybody's like oh I'm
clapping and stuff but I go so big that
the show is not like so so long so it's
like a nice show we start with the
smaller ones still go but then the
little Batman
it's like you know we do like a fifth I
do like a 13 to 15 minute bang but like
it's a long time so we go the next night
we go to a party and like now I'm not
the host I don't gotta Grill [ __ ] I
don't got to do anything now I get to
put my feet up with my family and I get
to let somebody else be the Fourth of
July you know host and party and all of
a sudden it's nine o'clock comes New
York everyone hey guys fireworks in like
15 minutes we're by the pool having a
drink wow this is great this [ __ ]
dude backed up a pickup truck he backed
up the Italian kid Italian kids can they
have to just go big this guy's garage
looked like you go to Vegas dude this
guy they know a guy yeah I always know a
guy this guy went he pulled up his
pickup truck and they went into the
cul-de-sac and they go all right
everybody out in the front yard this
month for 55 minutes oh my God this
[ __ ] guy blew up this guy and I'm
just sitting there I'm going oh this is
nice
and my son just walks over and he just
goes it's all right Dad
shows and I go what the [ __ ] so now next
year what's up get up he's over no next
year next year I'm now I'm gonna I'm
going 56 minutes do you want the promise
I don't want to watch firecrackers 56
minutes that's too long I don't either
you're 15 you're good bro after 10 I'm
like got it oh yeah yeah a little girl a
little girl who's friends with you know
all the kids know each other little girl
goes I like the verses one a little
better because it's like shorter this
one just kind of kept going on so that
made me feel good but my son walking
over looking at me just it you know he
let me he knew like that I was kind of
call like called out without being
called out so I was like okay take a
break let's take a break dude here we
are the break boys the break room bro
the break break room boys break room
boys break room boys break room always
break room always break room boys got a
little weird at the end it was tough now
you're eating um some ice cream cake got
some stressed out dude you need to talk
don't be stressed dude you know what
happens to me I get stressed and I don't
think it gets better with age I wake up
in the middle of the night I wake up too
early cold sweat I fret all the time I
need help because I work out you gotta
talk about professional dude you work on
your body but you got to work on the
brain that's where our friends that
better help come into place Man online
therapy there are plenty of ways to
support your healthy brain like learning
new language or taking power naps but
listen there's also online therapy with
better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat only therapy sessions so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to but you can look it's
a here's the main thing if you need help
therapy is really expensive when it's in
person this is way more affordable than
in-person therapy but here's the thing
he's either still talking about
professional you're still on the phone
you're still Skyping you're still
connecting with somebody it's also a lot
more yeah man it's also a lot more
affordable than in-person therapy you
can be matched with a licensed therapist
in under 48 hours maybe and right now
the fire kid listeners and viewers get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com fighter that's better
h-e-l-p.com fighter look man sometimes
you want your paycheck now you don't
want to wait three days because you need
cash now and you got bills and the bills
aren't the bills you call them up and
say I'm sorry I didn't get my paycheck
that's what I'm saying you want an app
where you can just go bang right okay
let me tell you something right now you
can pay bills you can feel good about
your money situation I'm talking about
chime yes thank God there's chime in now
you can get your paycheck at the two
days early with direct deposit Daddy
it's an award-winning mobile app
checking your account debit card
optional savings account okay and what
are you waiting for here you know
hopefully not your paycheck right so get
started with chime chime okay applying
for a free can take less than two
minutes get started with chime at
chime.com that's
c-h-i-m-e.com slash fighter that's
chime.com fighter banking services debit
card provided by The Bancorp Bank of
stride bank and a members FDIC Early
Access to direct deposit funds depends
on payers chime.com fighter okay did the
I know a couple that adopted a dog and
and they brought it to the beach on 4th
of July in Manhattan Beach and they
these high school kids were letting off
those giant amenities that you shoot in
the air like boom you know that's like
we're like oh Jesus yeah yeah well that
dog heard that sound and just started
running and didn't stop running
now my dog loses they lost that dog that
dog they didn't find that dog okay she
lost that dog they lost that forever
well that's what it does to dogs what it
does to a dog's psyche it's like it's
really like almost torturous so I said
one year my dog got out he's [ __ ]
freaking out because he's trying to
protect he's biting at the Sparks he's
trying to protect us yes and I go get
the [ __ ] dog inside because to them
even when like even when he hears a
neighbor from far away he just hears a
pop he goes up it it does something to
their ears but to them it's like an
attack yeah
you wouldn't lose him [ __ ] Vietnam
Iraq like seven times make that loud
noise yeah but that don't you talk ran
it never came back save yourself the dog
ran down the big piece of [ __ ] like
through the sand yeah how fast they can
run his ears packed like that running
running and a DOT on the horizon see you
later like Hussein ball looking for the
dog all [ __ ] day god dude I've never
found it again
one of the funniest things I've ever
seen in my life I was I talked about
this on the version effect years and
years ago and I was crying I couldn't
get it out there was a but there was
like a marathon like a bunch of joggers
yeah and it was like through a
neighborhood it was like for a cause and
you know the way when a dog sees people
run it just runs this poor [ __ ] dog
just comes out in a parade of people and
just kept going and it just couldn't
stop it just kept following people and
it wouldn't stop dude no and it ended up
going five I couldn't fit just exhausted
my buddy my buddy in Philly I told the
story before but he got out of he beat
up a bunch of cops he's the biggest
strongest guy in the world he he's
picking cops up throwing them they're
[ __ ] hitting with billy clubs and
they they'd let the dog out on him this
is the other oh he's going to jail you
fight a bunch of cops in Philly you're
going to jail it was the 90s yeah
because now we're gonna shoot it's in
the 90s and you're gonna get it's in the
90s and it might have even been in the
late 80s yeah you're gonna get the
[ __ ] K well either way nobody has
cameras you're gonna get this [ __ ]
kicked out dude you punch a cop it's
really [ __ ] well and in Philly in
Philly he was uh he was he was a
football player and and played on on
played for pen so he's picking these
guys up and if he's [ __ ] he's drunk
and he's fighting them all and he's your
size and so uh they let the dog out on
him and the only reason he didn't get
[ __ ] any charges was because the dog
comes out he sees the dog he takes a cop
throws it on the dog the dog the cop
falls on the dog the dog kind of you
know disoriented and then my buddy kicks
the dog in the [ __ ] ass just kicks it
really hard in the ass there's a canine
dog German I mean the German Shepherd
gets disoriented sees a dude
across the street running he was running
you know I don't know to his car or
something yeah those dogs their prey
drive kicks in dog goes that's the
Target no runs across the street bites
the guy here oh my God right on the side
now that's a wolf and they don't laugh
they don't let go of that laugh they'll
start ripping so gets him here and start
to shake and obviously that's how he got
out now when his jeopard get yeah you go
oh you fall down yeah well the lawyer it
becomes a huge case and the [ __ ] it's
like you know it made there's a he has
the article framed it made there's a
there's this giant black female cop in a
neck race like Tessa he got off because
that dog because that guy was suing the
department they wanted it all to go away
no bro those canine cops will kill you
on the news you know in La I don't know
how's where you're in New York if
there's like a high speed chase do they
stop everything like it's [ __ ]
nuclear war no like here like Ukraine
Russia War just got announced they
stopped all of it just to show this dude
in a [ __ ] Prius on a highway like I
guess it's important here it's a big
deal yeah dude two nights ago I'm
watching I can't get enough of me anyway
I'm watching it this dude stole some car
he's on the run I'm like let's see how
this pans out and the cops aren't
allowed to chase him you know that they
have to back off because they don't want
him to like wreck other people so they
follow behind they fall behind pretty
far right and kind of just like that
yeah because someone died they were
chasing them and the the the criminal
like veered to the right and killed
somebody so now that by law they have to
back off they follow him and hope he
runs out of gas and they'll do a thing
so this dude's doing he's going down 101
right here he's [ __ ] gone down
they're falling I'm like well this is it
there's a full tank of stick [ __ ]
hours yeah he [ __ ] pulls over goes to
get out they just someone was like
really still [ __ ] hound and this is
live on TV so he's running down the
[ __ ] highway someone released the
hounds and I I apparently I saw this bro
I just saw that the the commentators
out of the highway the newscast didn't
know how to deal with it because it's
live so they can't edit this dude gets a
night of them
you see him on life
oh let's take a break multiple dogs yeah
that's right yeah no I think it was one
it was one Belgium let's take a break
they're like oh you know what we will
keep you posted like oh no you just
blood and arms are going up on the
ground neck and you're just like okay
let's uh well we're gonna take a quick
or those Shepherds
fantastic that's fine my buddy my buddy
he's walking down he and and this other
group they're they're football players
they start they're they're fighting
they're talking back and forth back this
[ __ ] you know that that [ __ ] New
York [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] but this is
Philly actually in Pennsylvania blah
blah blah so there's a park next thing
you know my friend starts fighting with
this other dude and they're [ __ ]
going at it and my buddy goes I'm
getting the best of the guy on top and
all of a sudden these homeless dudes
would jump on my back these these bums
they're all raggedy and stuff and they
jump they're all dirty but the thing is
they're [ __ ] strong and the next
thing I know he's get he's got one guys
on his arm the other guy's arm the other
guy's on his legs and they're carrying
him
he's being carried by these homeless
guys sacrifice but he but he's gone
they're taking them you think you're
gonna take him to their Lair and he's
going oh
he's screaming uh he looks over his
friends aren't helping his friends are
are being talked to by a cop
they weren't homeless dudes they were
[ __ ] cops on a sting and they had
this whole thing and these [ __ ]
idiots ruined the whole you [ __ ]
idiot and so I couldn't figure out why
they were [ __ ] so [ __ ] strong they
were all cut they were all just Jack
cops who were [ __ ] that's like you
ruined everything you [ __ ] idiot we
were waiting to do this I don't know
what they were gonna do but yeah these
homeless guys are really strong
and they also seemed fat yeah he's like
they were so strong because I can't
[ __ ] move and they were taken he
thought he was they were taking him
somewhere nope now Paul your Swagger is
a little different right what you came
in here the Swagger's a little different
now that you're a very famous comic
because you're special blew up on
Netflix I feel like you're looking down
upon what's your special call about them
my special is called nocturnal
admissions oh great and it's crazy and
it's doing it's doing I'm very dude I'm
grateful it's crazy crushing it's funny
it's crust no no it's uh it was it's
nice to put it out there and have have
the reviews be what they are and people
word of mouth is really getting out and
people know this is like you know people
are like hey man thanks for killing it
that it feels good man and uh you're on
a PR tornado are you sick of talking
doing you know what I'm saying because
we do a lot of podcasts right now
tomorrow's the last day and I'm like you
know I and I actually I'm doing this
thing where like I just want to do it
with guys I know and friends like
there's one thing about doing there's
one thing about doing podcasts but like
I know you guys not been on here you
guys have been nice enough to have me a
bunch of times and you know uh I'm good
friends with Tim Dillon so I did Tim's
it and there's just a report because we
know each other Burr we know each other
like I'll do other shows but I like talk
it doesn't get as boring and and when
it's just but like going to some place
where Hey man nice to meet you on Paul
yeah oh thanks for stopping by and then
I'm doing this you know and plus there's
only so many stories I don't like to
repeat myself like there's a couple
things you have to say oh you'll like
this but yeah you know what I mean you
know you do you do that PR [ __ ] it gets
like when you were with a friend we
could you know like we were out there
talking about like how fun with the
firing people thing yeah and it's like
you know it's not forced the hard the
worst thing is when it's forced how long
is it special
65 minutes oh wow yeah 65. amazing yeah
hour and five and I'll give you 65. I
like yeah I give you six I will give you
every bit of it so I'm editing mine I'm
adding it down 43 minutes I was told to
do it a shorter version but I guess it
doesn't depend yeah but yeah it also
depends on the set that night and how
how editing is like because if you're
like because I would rather have like if
mine was if they were like Paul yours is
a little over an hour but like if we get
it to 48 is real then I would do the but
I just I I was working on this and I was
ready to go yeah and I was ready to do
it so yeah do it at its best you gotta
feel a sense of relief right because
you're one of those guys it's almost
like uh and I don't say Bill Burke
they're like Bill Burr's moment was
right in Philly with the Rocky statue
thing that he blew up but he's been
doing comedy for a hot second or like
Lucy K like I feel like you're one of
those monster Comics that have just been
grinding and then finally you're getting
your dude you know I'll be honest with
you man it was it was no there's
definitely some truth to that like there
was times during the pandemic where
people were putting stuff out and people
were doing these podcasts and and I'm
not saying this arrogantly but if I'm
gonna be honest and candy like I would
be like dude these [ __ ] people don't
know what I'm about to like I'm I'm out
here working and I'm doing it and people
like oh dude you're crowd work the jokes
and and nobody knew so I would be like
you know talking to my wife oh they went
great but it started to get old in a way
when when waitresses would be like man
I've been here years I see everybody we
stopped and watch you like you're one of
the funniest people as great as that
felt it started to get annoying because
I'm like but then then I knew and when
Netflix saw it and goes like this
belongs here this belongs here and we're
putting it out I knew when people were
telling me and like dude I had legendary
Comics go hit me up and just say like
people that were like I was just like
wow but dude the work was put in I was
going on the road I was honing that hour
I was adding things I was ad-lib and I
was putting things in and it was ready
to go so as much as yeah it's it's not
like getting my dude but like letting
people see it the work is when the work
it would be like I guess if like you
know a UFC fighter finally gets on that
state gets in that thing on a
pay-per-view or whatever it is and all
of a sudden man like it comes together
and people go oh [ __ ] and then it but I
would I remember dude because I remember
actually guys like Jim Norton and and
guys like guys like burn guys that like
kind of were on the longer path they're
just you can't [ __ ] with that that you
know because
so it's one thing to go out there and
start killing it you've got it and and
and you know something on the Internet
pops and you've been doing it eight
years and all of a sudden you're getting
everything but then then you know to Sis
to sustain I would rather be the guy
that was 20 years like just went long
road but ready yeah ready because I
don't want [ __ ] to every everything I
put out I want to be as good or or
better so I did myself you got to do it
again I mean that's that's the other
thing like you don't stop now you can't
and that's the thing when people were
going like my manager my wife people
like are you happy like can you enjoy
this as much as I can enjoy it I'm like
I gotta so one thing I was
nerve-wracking was I went to San Diego
the week after this drop this dropped
June 23rd Netflix I went to San Diego
and people hit me up Rosie should we
come or should we watch your special
which one I go no no come I'm ready and
I was like in my mind I'm going all
right I think I like this do I have 62
minutes in San Diego and it was like and
I'm going okay now that I have this
blueprint of the set where is it's going
to be in a year but I want it to be as
good if not better or it doesn't come
out that's the thing like when you've
learned when you've done it so long it's
like it's going to be as good or better
as far as me like me feeling like when
nocturnal is me and one of the best
reviews I got was I was like if you want
to know who Paul verzi is who his comedy
is who his life is who his family is
everything about him the type of person
he is watch that because that's who he
is and that's what made me feel good and
now I just want the next one to be an
extension of that and I'm not putting it
out if that in my mind and eyes isn't
that that's good yeah but I feel but I
feel like you're the Comics comic like
you had the approval
from all the big boys
I think they you know guys
saw me grinding for a while and killing
and they were just like you know your
time I remember I remember uh I think
burst said something where Chappelle
said something to him like a guy like
you it'll take longer but when it hits
it's gonna hit and Burke kind of said to
me he's like same thing he's like you
know he's like Pete when it's you know
Burr would say things that I couldn't
even believe he would say I've been
making like yeah dude you're gonna start
selling that club you're gonna get into
fears I could do I'm making three what
the [ __ ] I'm making 300 this week I
don't know what are you what do you know
Robert said something nice when he's
done saying sometimes he goes go [ __ ]
yourself they'll just see oh no the boss
I do a joke about that like Boston guys
can never give you like when you go to
Boston and you perform they'll be like
where is he kid funny [ __ ] I took my
girl I don't get excited I'm not trying
to blow you okay like I always have to
you [ __ ] better yeah yeah yeah
same thing like the guy looks at me and
goes I kid I know the [ __ ] you are and I
don't know what I I that's it he goes I
know yeah like I don't know if he's
gonna punch me or hug me yeah yeah they
almost have a hard time giving it up so
when they give it up there has to be a
little bit well you better say thanks
because he's looking at you going I gave
you a little something I'm waiting now
yeah
but sometimes they'll do [ __ ] without
what's up yeah dude you're like I don't
know like what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
bird crushed the room one time with the
laugh factor and I go dude I'm telling
you right now that [ __ ] was the great
you are the best right now and he goes
ah yeah thanks I don't know and then he
calls me the next day and he goes hey
man listen I just want to thank you for
that you know yeah because and then he
goes but just go [ __ ] yourself at the
end of it yeah because but but that it
does mean dude uh uh one guy dude Brian
Regan reached out and I was just like
dude for me it's top for me it's top ten
epic yeah and he's just like hey man and
I was just like what like it was like
that meant like you know having guys
like that because they recognize like
the work and they also recognize like
the joke and the story and just not
letting up I don't want to [ __ ]
half-ass it if I'm gonna put something
out there I remember when we did that I
said to my wife and my team I go man I
want I want every I want everywhere to
see it and then I want all I ask for is
everybody sees it and this goes where it
belongs yeah and but what's tough is
you're just waiting for a call that's
the thing about our businesses it's not
we put it out we do it and then all of a
sudden they tell you what's what's fun
what you're worthy of them you're like
oh [ __ ] all right it's a tough [ __ ]
business man but you can't [ __ ] with
work and you can't [ __ ] with the jokes
and you can't [ __ ] with funny but but
I'll see you in two years because you
gotta get back to work now it's like You
Gotta Throw all that [ __ ] away that's
exactly right and and we start again and
you just like I'm in that right now I I
don't know if he's a uh New Yorker I
don't know I know he's known for
traveling all around but I have to
follow Tom Rhodes yeah I've known Thomas
yeah
he's been doing it so Tom's been doing
it Tom is really famous on MTP when he
was younger and and then he kind of Hit
the road and just Tom for literally 10
years didn't have an address he lived in
hotels I guess he's known for like doing
stand-up all over the world yeah but no
he was known what made his name was in
the 90s he was on Comedy Central on MTV
he used to work a lot with John didn't
work a lot with John Fox he was good
friends with John Fox I just ran into
him I literally ran into it I've never
heard of him and then uh Rita who runs
uh The Improv uh I was coming from the
Laugh Factory and she said okay are you
close and she's I can't I can have Tom
go longer and she was basically like
also heads up you're following uh uh
Rhodes I was like yeah cool you know
yeah it happens
dude but he was he ran long he was doing
his crowd work dude my god oh killer he
was like hey he was like nairu is in
here from L.A he's at my thing is I've
literally toured all over the world and
he's like uh tell me where you're from
it was just people Australia had a whole
bid on Australia oh yeah that's one of
the Eagles where are you you guys aren't
families no way for melon and he goes
where are you from she goes Venezuela is
I don't have any Venezuela material he
goes but I do have a really good uh
Japan bit you know so whenever I say
Venezuela you guys think Japan and did
and he goes so I was in Venezuela and I
met this Samurai dude bro he [ __ ]
corrupted
that was [ __ ] unbelievable and then
he watched it where he comes back green
and he goes man they're [ __ ] hot and
I go Tom I think it's your Mateo buddy
yeah he's a God please awesome thanks
dude monsters I love seeing it and it's
Cadence and following that is great like
so many like somebody said someone to be
like I like to know him like to know
where you're at like to get in that
sweet spot that's easy it's like you're
going to go home and feel good because
you had a good set but find out where
you're where you're [ __ ] at dude I
used to I came up I came up in New York
before I was like doing any main clubs I
came up in Black rooms because they were
like oh white boy's funny put them up
it'd be 250 old and it was dude and it
was New York City dude it was like
they're not giving it up unless you are
really funny it was like yeah and it was
like the New York Kings of Comedy it was
like uh talent and Capone and Rob
Stapleton and uh Gerald Kelly and all
these guys man and Drew Frazier and
these guys are coming up and these rooms
are [ __ ] packed and and Def Jam type
[ __ ] and I had to do it and I remember
one night uh they had a Laugh Factory in
Times Square it was it was short-lived
and it was Wendy Williams called Wendy
Williams uh comedy experience on
Wednesday nights in Times Square pack
that and it was always packed Capone
dude this guy's he was his name was
Capone he was you know uh he'd come in
you know big dude Charming dude but just
like he just came in and it was Def Jam
[ __ ] and Wendy Williams had a table on
the stage but far off and you would go
up and it was like Prime Time [ __ ]
Wednesday nights dude it was nuts and I
remember uh he's like yeah I'm put you
on me funny man right I'm just waiting
and everyone's killing and uh Dean
Edwards goes before me and Dean Edwards
is doing a set and everything's going
normal and dude he [ __ ] goes into
Denzel and his Denzel [ __ ] explodes
the room and he's and it's like Denzel
Training Day [ __ ] crushing then he goes
into another one and then another one he
did like three and this [ __ ] dude
this place is jumping out of their skin
and the dude comes up to me and he goes
hey man if you want to go later if you
want to go later you know we could
because you know everyone's going crazy
in here if you know nobody not too many
people know if you want to go later or
you know and I go I gotta go now and I
said I gotta go now and and I went up
now and I had a I had what did you do
how did you open it was I opened with
this was America I did a joke about
American Idol about how they made them
sing after they were kicked off yeah
that's insulting yeah so it's like
you're gonna make so and I remember
Wendy Williams really laughing at that
and then everybody got going and once I
got that joke in wait so I don't the
joke was what the joke was like because
an American Idol after
yeah
and I picture my father like you know
you guys know I've talked about my dad
but like I picked that made me because
my father would be like will you [ __ ]
just you think I'm gonna and and that's
where my mind went like you're gonna
make me go up there like the you just
copied me you just cut them and then so
I remember like doing the joke like how
it was ridiculous I don't know exactly
how it went but I got Wendy Williams and
I started to get them and then I ended
up taking what Dean did and do it but a
lot of people don't want to do that but
why not find out where you really are
because at least you know at least I
don't want to follow that person and
here's the other thing don't try to you
know you could Pace back and forth and
be like I gotta You're Never Gonna
Change what you do so it's like let them
do it and if they have either energy or
if they [ __ ] do a backflip or
whatever they do and then you go then
then you're gonna go and be your voice
well I was starting to do it I was
starting Rogan about this on Thursday
and we're talking about how when we came
up you got up in front of strangers you
came up you gotta yes like like when you
like for the first 15 years of my
stand-up career I would go to wherever
that city was and I didn't know anybody
and they sure as [ __ ] didn't know and
they were all different yeah yeah now
one of the things that is with podcast
you can curate your own audience so
they're there they come to laugh so in a
way it doesn't demand that's a great
[ __ ] point yeah it doesn't mean it
gives you in some ways a false sense of
security because when it used to be like
the [ __ ] Comedy Store pack in the day
before podcasting dude I would be
performing at one in the morning for 12
alcoholics I'm telling you yeah you'd be
up there or they just 25 people who
hated your guts who didn't know where
the [ __ ] you were they were from all
over the world they were yeah they were
from all over the world they were
tourists who would like stumble in and
[ __ ] and you couldn't see the audience
if you could do well in that [ __ ]
room yeah you could do well anywhere
yeah when you were learning there or and
by the way [ __ ] the comic strip the
seller stand up New York it was all the
same [ __ ] when you were in New York you
got in front of New Yorkers back then
before it got it was really rich you had
a mix of people man yeah bridge and
tunnel and everything else yeah and
sorry man if you don't make them laugh
with [ __ ] that's relevant to them New
York comedy club I did was all black
you'd get up there and if you don't
bring the money I ate all the dicks one
time yeah I I had so many dicks that I
got so quiet that this lone woman goes
wow
she goes wow I was like oh I'm gonna
quit stand up yeah but now in a way you
can already your your audience is
already excited to see you and it's it
is what it is but you know podcasting
has created that for for people yeah
yeah I think so and I think like trust
we also weren't making money nobody made
money no you weren't making money but
you know why though but and that and
that that's I shouldn't say you know why
that mentality of not making money but
still doing it yeah yeah it actually
follows you into success because you see
people doing things I see people doing
things right now and I'm going like what
the [ __ ] are you doing that for but I
was talking to Brandon before before we
went on the air and what bugs me is
these [ __ ] Comics who were like you
know and maybe I take it more personally
because I have a family but these Comics
like yeah man I'm out you know I don't
even get to see my I don't even get to
see my kids and it's like [ __ ] you dude
you know what like you can see your kids
you make it like listen I'm doing pretty
[ __ ] well and I'm not missing a big
first thing I may miss one game in the
season but I'm not gonna [ __ ] miss
these guys are going like man you know
like there's no time and it's it's like
no man that you're selfish and you want
[ __ ] attention instead of going to
your daughter's [ __ ] dance recital
you need that because something is
[ __ ] up in you so you'd rather [ __ ]
and what are you gonna do on your
deathbed you're gonna be okay with the
fact that your little daughter's in
tears while you made some fat [ __ ] in
Tacoma laugh and she's upset because
that's what that's that's really the
reality of this Fort Wayne worth it yeah
so what you get like 15 20 grand
whatever it is 10 grand whatever it is
that weekend and your daughter's crying
and you get some new fans and and I
don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm just saying
if you're a successful actor if you're
you're a film actor you're a TV actor
but especially if you're a film actor
you're gone and you don't see your kids
so basically in the military The
Punisher uh John uh
John barenthal uh you mean him sat next
to each other and I was like oh the [ __ ]
that's the Punisher I'm a huge fan of me
and I don't say anything and he kept
stabbing me I'm like yeah that's the kid
is that the kid in a Wolf of Wall Street
too no he's uh he's in uh he's in
Chicago he was in a Wolf of Wall Street
was he yeah so he's on the plane and
then um he goes hey man big fan go oh
[ __ ] like he says I'm the biggest fan I
didn't want to be a weirdo me and him
were going I was going to New York we
talked for the full six hours we're
writing we talked full six hours and I
was telling him about how I struggle
with leaving my family stuff like that
and he's like I get it man you know I
have four kids and he goes here's my
thing he goes dude I'll be done for six
months yeah when I shoot whatever movie
it is six months he was six months and
he was and sometimes and I'll bring my
kids where you're talking Bulgaria but
when you bring your kids you're working
16 hours but he said I go well can't you
certain sets don't you bring me because
I I wouldn't see him he so these kids
these poor kids are stuck in the [ __ ]
trailer yeah you go you go back to the
hotel and the kids are sleeping it's not
you that's what he said he's like he's
not working I was at school and they
also have lives so that's what they said
they're not going to come to Tiberia try
being a working actor man he's like you
think would stand up he's like at least
yeah you can no more control he goes
with me he goes some three six four
months I I could not for me you can't
you don't see your wife you don't see
anything but you're in the military it's
like he's such a good dude yeah
oh man such a down there yeah I've heard
great things about that he's really
close to Joey Diaz is he really close
yeah because you slide it out there and
he'll say I could do this I guess shoot
this he's like but I'm something he's
like you know Joey right like hell yeah
he said I'm doing his part I think yeah
he's great
yeah he's great he lives in uh Ohio
get him on that's great is he originally
a New York guy or no uh he's DC yeah I
don't know but he's interesting because
uh you know he went to school at [ __ ]
he went to Harvard
did he yeah yeah he's a smart [ __ ]
dude grew up like Ralph but then went to
[ __ ] Harvard
I don't think he got rough but he's a
smart guy yeah you're right bro yeah DC
DC yep the kid went to Harvard Skidmore
and then Harvard yeah wow yeah he's he's
a good [ __ ] guy
yeah he's a really good dude that's so
cool man yeah no it's it's you know
listen man you got families don't it's I
never wanted this business to make me
miss something big man a first thing you
know if it was the first thing I can't
miss I can't miss my son's first Little
League game I can't just you know and
I'll tell the agent now like look I got
this like my agent got me a date and I
go ah dude I go that's the daddy
daughter dance man you know oh there's
not enough money in the world especially
once my son starts playing like high
school football I missed one out of all
the daddy-daughter dances I missed one
my stepfather went for me it was
something dates got screwed up last
minute and then and even then when she
was I go never like never never no no
I'm going to the daddy door yeah yeah
because that's a life that's her memory
of her dad forever you take that picture
it's like yeah like no you can't man
does that kids kids feel it my son my
family is starting to feel my son and
daughter's starting to feel now they're
starting to feel it and like they start
to feel that you know more people
recognize me for what I do and and I can
tell that and I and I sit down I'm like
listen none of that nothing that will
ever happen it's like let's go to the
Yankee game let's go let's go do that
you're setting a great example too and
you're setting an example of what to be
and that is a very powerful thing so
there's there's another school of
thought which also says you still can't
compre you don't want to use your
children as an excuse for not being as
good as you could be so it's a dance
right it's a trade-off and and of course
you want to make time with your kids and
see your kids but they're also you know
it took a lot of work for you to get
here and you're only going to keep
growing and that's something they're
going to be very proud of you could get
sad when you leave now myself my son's
six and just now like he'll get Max I'll
put them to bed and then I have sets in
La when I'm in town so you know two
three times a night I'm leave I put in
bed and it was probably because I'll be
in shorts in the tank top and in uh at
home but I know so I have my clothes on
he's where are you going yeah I'm
putting your bed dude and I got sets
because you have to work tonight dude
now he knows when I leave it's I saw
that clip of your son going Sea World I
was like that that's it yeah like yeah
San Diego yeah yeah San Diego we're
going to Sea World no we're not going
well you said before about the jersey at
the All-Star Game my son will be like
what city and then he starts going
through the players that play yeah it's
like if they got something at the
airport with a jersey and I'm like you
know but like yeah so he's a huge
Sportsman he's a huge sports fan huge
basketball fan but uh he's just gotten
really it's the weirdest thing dude I
don't know what it is he's a he's an
athlete he loves he always watching
YouTube basketball playing 2K basketball
and now lately I go in his room and he's
just watching fishing videos
hey B can we take another little break
when chatting with our one of our
favorite Paul version only if it's about
money only if it's about me making money
not for anything other than laugh
ing dude I gotcha and listen that's why
my friends at draftking Sportsbook you
can watch your favorite sport and bet on
it and make money bro bet on your
favorite sports all summer long for a
football season right now and listen new
customers can get a risk-free bet up to
one thousand dollars just make your
first bet up to one thousand dollars and
if it doesn't hit you another shot of a
big win that's right feel the thrill of
every Sports season whole new way by
betting on baseball baseball's popping
right now golf MMA UFC and so much more
plus with the same game parlay spreads
money lines over unders and props your
betting options feel endless best of all
DraftKings a safe secure reliable
deposit withdraw your cash whenever you
want Man download the draft game sports
book app right now use promo code
fighter make your first deposit and get
a risk-free bet up to one thousand
dollars that's promo code fighter only
at draftking Sportsbook minimum age
eligibility restrictions apply C show
notes for details see next page for a
direction of disclaimer that's
DraftKings download the app use the
promo code fighter but uh he's just
gotten really it's the weirdest thing
dude I don't know what it is he's a he's
an athlete he loves you're always
watching YouTube basketball playing 2K
basketball and now lately I go in his
room and he's just watching fishing
videos
what he ordered like he ordered a
fishing pole I took him to [ __ ] it's
so interesting I was into fishing dude I
go I take him to Dick's Sporting Goods
and I was like what's a good Poll for
you know I said he's 13 he's like that's
a real good one and he goes does
research he goes now that line could
only get a 12 to 15 pound fish I go I go
where do you think we're and that's when
you start talking about Panama so a
thing comes in the I think a thing comes
in the mail can't start talking about
I'm like this is the number one fishing
in the world and I was like well we got
a lake around the [ __ ] corner so yeah
he's not getting on a plane to Panama
yeah yeah I'm like what are you trying
to catch by the way he's a little you
know you're not catching Marlins yeah
the Amazon guy comes with a package and
I go Stacy in it and Stacy goes oh and
he goes oh it's my fishing stuff he
ordered a line that like they got shark
that gets shot like like sure you're not
catching brains sharks are awesome you
gotta have you gotta have a line it can
happen well you know if I cast and we go
out there in the ocean like what if I
get some so this this line will do it
then he's got like this like the
Cadillac of [ __ ] he goes look at that
reel look how smooth it is you want to
laugh I'm in my living room going
so he's like really like he's just he's
as long as they're into something like
my son listen if he's into fishing dude
I don't know fishing like I went fishing
in Milwaukee and that like dude I I
would like catch fish and you know these
guys were like this I can't we're really
on a [ __ ] big fish guy goes Texas
that's a sheephead I'm like hey yeah
let me take a picture [ __ ] Uh Kevin
catches the [ __ ] you can't eat that
past this big I go it's a [ __ ] oh I'm
like this one and I swear to God goes
man small mouth I'm like let me know
but I'm with your son I I grew up being
really inefficient I love really yeah my
uncle Charlie my my uncle Skippy stick
me all the time and same thing I catch
something for I'm I'm eight dude let me
[ __ ] take in the glory same thing as
trap yeah trash trash I'm eight dude let
me just do the [ __ ]
as long as your son's in I don't give a
[ __ ] what it is and you know unless you
know it could get dicey but as long as
they're into some passionate about
something yeah probably I won't say who
it is but my son's best friend his dad's
very famous and uh they're into Pokemon
cards well I was into cards as a kid but
I collect like Joe Montana and [ __ ]
Junior say out yeah yeah Ryan Sandberg
the Pokemon the [ __ ] cartoons they're
[ __ ] but they're expensive so that
takes them to the [ __ ] local car shop
600 in cards so my son comes home each
of them comes home Daddy I'm like Jesus
Christ and in my head because I bought
him cars I'm like holy [ __ ] dude and I
was like hey Bubba that's not no that
was like a one-off battle yeah every
time we go then that can't be a hobby no
and then my dad was in town and he
convinced my taking the store and he's
like you know Grandma Pete only got me
I'm like not it's not only dude that's a
big deal man yeah yeah it's hard to
understand it's like they don't they
don't it's not his fault hard to instill
it's a balance of making your children
appreciate things that hard work can
achieve and not you know and not being
spoiled but also like that you want them
to have better than what you have so
it's like that middle thing and you also
got to watch like what people do one
thing that I learned is like you got to
watch what people say family members say
around your kids now I'm at the age
where they're 13 and 10. you know like
I'll be honest and I I love I love my
father my father's in Florida man and
I'm like my father said some wild [ __ ]
so it's like I gotta watch it because
then he'll be like he'll be like hey
Grandpa it you know and and I'll be like
what do you you know what do you mean
and I gotta and my wife anybody you know
you get people come over they'll either
talk politics or either talk religion
even amongst them so and the kids take
it in so they'll get off the bus and
they're like oh well I heard Uncle
so-and-so said this but in school they
said this they'll get off the bus and be
like I heard this guy's a real bad
person and I'm like but you gotta like
there's a that's a one-sided thing so
you got to be because they hear it now
they they're their sponges dude you know
what like a lot of countries they'll
have a mandatory draft right especially
for boys and part of that part of the
philosophy there is that you might be
spoiled you might have had a cushy life
you're in the [ __ ] Army now bro and
you're gonna do what everybody else does
yeah especially the kid around the block
who grew up with nothing and you're all
the same you're all the same and also
though it really brings you into contact
with objective reality you're not going
to sleep as much you're not gonna eat
your mom's not there [ __ ] off this is
two years we got you for two years and
this is what's gonna happen there's a
lot of value and [ __ ] I give a sense of
Pride yeah Nation like it's important I
would be mad at that yes yeah I think
that's where Sports comes into play
sports is very blessed like you know but
it also teaches you no matter how much
money you have yeah it's disciplined and
hard work yeah and it's hard work and
the hard work is going to make your
skills you know but it's also humbling
like it's also like in a good way like
you're not gonna win 24 7. yeah it's
good for them to lose and figure it out
and have to come back I wonder about I
wonder about fighting in the game that
you were in in the UFC I wonder if like
a guy that comes up and let's just say a
kid comes up and his dad's got rolls
royces and he but he could fight and and
he said [ __ ] he's a monster and he comes
from money and he's a monster but then
he's fighting a dude that comes from the
[ __ ] gutter I wonder if if that like
I mean would that have to come in two
exceptions right yeah do you know
somebody that's right there I don't know
grew up rich there's that one guy cater
his family has a lot of money yeah Calum
cater yeah his family has a lot of money
and DJ Penn apparently those two have a
lot of money but that's the only those
the only people I know see that's an
interesting thing that like coming yeah
like not many people that come from
mansions and living like growing up like
that and then all of a sudden they're
like that would be a [ __ ] that'd be why
yeah maybe football though in basketball
it's too it's too hard of a of a gig
like it's kind of like a stand-up like
can you imagine like if you're like how
funny is Eddie Murphy's kid you know
like your dad has all that money like my
parents had a brutal like I went through
some brutal [ __ ] I'm sure you like you
go through brutal [ __ ] you want to get
acceptance and you use your talent to
kind of move up I think but then if your
family like no matter what you try out
it doesn't matter if you fail I don't
know if you're gonna make them stand up
or [ __ ] [ __ ] that's a good yeah
that's a way this is too hard yeah I'm
fighting like you you have to be Noah
Plan B yeah
man I think you imagine when you were
going through this if you're you're in
Syracuse on a Wednesday night and then
your mom calls you like honey we'll just
give you 30 000 just get out of there
like [ __ ] it yeah do you imagine yeah I
know you can't if you have a plan B
you're kind of behind the eight ball
yeah um he I think his family has some
kind of like Calvin Kate yeah I think
they're super rich really yeah like
really rich but that's the only person I
know he's got his own Fight League now
and stuff I wonder
your right favorite no I'm thinking
about counting okay
no I know he is I know exactly yeah that
they were talking about I just had him
on food truck he's been on twice yeah
yeah we've had him he's a Boston through
and through man his older brothers I
don't think so dude I'm not seeing a
Fight League let me see let me see what
it looks like
yeah it's a middle that's the guy yeah
that's the guy back in Texas
yeah that's his manager on the left
they're from the New England cartel
those boys are hey Brandon do a lot of
do a lot of the guys were a lot of guys
bullied a lot of the UFC fighters
bullied like is that was that uh I'm
sure I'm sure a good amount yeah yeah
well they probably I noticed that a lot
of them came from broken homes or some
kind of a thing at home I don't know if
they were bullied because a lot of times
they were tough and athletic and no no I
would say alarm came for broken homes
either that's like saying all athletes
own broken homes Fighters there's always
some dysfunction it's a little bit like
stand-ups you know it's like I don't
know there's always something you know
yeah it makes you think like what Tyson
would do if he wasn't in like imagine
Mike Tyson as a kid growing well boxers
that there's that's the old story with
boxers I mean it's very rare to find
like boxes that come from a lot of money
but with Tyson I said uh I said you know
Fighters we you know we come from you
know we come from the streets he goes no
no he stopped me no no boxers come from
the [ __ ] gutter all right yeah yeah
that's a he's that's a tough guy to just
start arguing with uh yeah like
he's really become he drops Mike Tyson
has become a very very special the
shrooms he's really worked out dude he
says some [ __ ] that's like so Steve well
think about the experience he's had like
highs and lows like you're gonna have
some dude crazy deep exp you know wisdom
to drop like yeah he said the other day
these guys are all listening he goes God
God gets back to you by giving you and
God gets back at you by giving you
everything you want
that's oh oh [ __ ] whoa whoa and he goes
and then he sits there see if you can
handle it and he goes anybody tells you
that you know a lot of money makes you
happy no matter yeah he says a lot but I
thought it was cool yeah some dark times
this guy's like nah man when people
[ __ ] do this I write him off and he
goes no no no then the devil wins he
goes no no I'm just saying with people
like this no because now you're letting
them change you yeah
yeah but think about how many
experiences he had to go through to
learn yeah
Bill Burr was liar he goes who hurt you
Bill's like
yeah it just [ __ ] annoys me and he
goes no no no hold on do you ever see
that no no man Mike Tyson's the only guy
who talked to Bill like this [ __ ] it
just bothers me makes me mad and Mike
goes no no hold on hold on something
happened to you man what do you mean it
hurts here
man he goes who hurts you man in high
school and Bill goes no I don't know he
goes no no no no no who hurt you and
Bill goes bill goes I mean I know I mean
I'm sure I had some things but you know
and Mike goes now you're being a silly
goose huh but you don't want you don't
wanna you don't want to get real
I was like I can't watch this just to me
Bill is the Mike Tyson of com like when
Billings are not around Mike Tyson
Bill's the one guy that scares me look
at me is the Mike Tyson in the 90s he's
always been great doing stuck up for me
like monster he's the one guy he's
working at such a high level you're like
because the question the question who
hurt you is so it's it's it's quick you
know what it is but it's a sniper shot
question because after that after those
words are asked especially by him hey
man yeah but also I would go where do I
start yeah yeah how long is this show
because is this an 18-hour show but oh
but the way he did it he goes like this
oh man I'll hurt you yeah I waited yeah
it was like comedy stop and Bill figured
his way out of it no he didn't figure
his way out I never saw it he still set
her you'll see I I never saw it that
makes me nervous it makes it made me
like I was like we're getting real now
do you ever see when Bill was on Theo
show you know Theo's a silly [ __ ]
goose and you know it was one time my
uncle you know my nickname and for you
know build forever that day was not
playing and was like what are you doing
what are you doing what is this you're
like oh yeah you know what's funny
we're so close like we're like family
but like a lot of stuff I don't see you
know like we're just like we talk on the
phone about oh I don't watch anything my
buddies do nothing like you I mean if
Ryan goes on a show and like it gets
traction like for whatever reason I'll
watch that but in general like you
haven't seen my standard man how long I
mean you know years right probably right
well when we performed together yeah in
San Antonio we both got covered yeah but
that was the last time
not really yeah but as long as you're
all right you know but if you go like if
you do a show or something if it makes
tracks like O'Brien said this and I'm
like oh let me check it out yeah but I
don't want any of my buddy's stuff none
of it yeah we're all like that I mean I
watch your special I blasted it out if
it's a special I'm on it but yeah but
like if you like I'll watch your episode
with Tim I love Tim yeah no I mean yeah
we had a good yeah like there's certain
things of course like if I see I'm more
of like I was actually saying this to uh
on Rogan it's like I'll I'm not gonna go
and watch an hour of Comedy but if I
scroll and I see a clip of a guy I love
or something I'll stop at a clip and be
like oh [ __ ] and then I'll hit that
person up and go dude I just saw that
thing you did it's really funny you know
I'm such a good friend like yours and
Chrissy D's all when we watch Netflix
like especially in the morning if my
kids you know they go to school and I'll
I'll leave it on just make sure it gets
in the algorithm in my head I'm like
this is helping them yeah keep replaying
this will help them that's right doesn't
do [ __ ] but no no like this is great no
but that's that's more comics were a
little more supportive in my opinion
you you know Paul doing well doesn't
take away from me right now yeah but you
also notice like I'm not a big like I'm
very I've always held my circle small
it's just who I am I'm not a guy like
I'm a type of guy like I meet somebody
and like right away when I meet the
person shake their hand talk I'm like I
can [ __ ] with that guy yeah right away
yeah
let's run into that guy dude that's my
guy and
I [ __ ] the other I'm not good with
comedy basketball games
do you think I'm gonna go to a comedy
poker night I'm not doing a comedy
[ __ ] kickball okay we're meeting at
the club and then we're gonna take a
show a shuttle I don't want to [ __ ]
see you when I perform
no these comments basketball yeah
take a shuttle right hey we're all gonna
meet at the club and we're gonna shuttle
down to the softball field hey how about
you never call me again yeah you really
oh that's how I know we're not friends
you know I would never if you knew me
you know that I'm sitting on my deck
with my children hanging out in the
country I mean even if it's a couple you
guys want to drive together I'll meet
you the thing is I'm not trying to fail
a media could you imagine calling your
friend hey do what number you're taking
for the softball team what bro you check
out this jersey you can play The
Outfield and [ __ ] what are you
thinking tonight man what the [ __ ] are
you what am I thinking yeah whatever
you're doing [ __ ] one in the morning
spots you know you're not even athletic
get the [ __ ] out of here
the [ __ ] you call me excited about this
grown adult yeah I'm trying to get a
jogging group together you want to meet
at this you're out of shape walking side
to side on a stage you fat [ __ ] telling
dick jokes think I'm gonna [ __ ] point
that is [ __ ] weird man that's so
funny listen but I also think family
guys have a different way of thinking me
and you like we have a different way of
thinking if you are in a [ __ ] Studio
or one bedroom and God bless those
people running around doing Spots You're
probably psyched on a Sunday to play
softball instead of being you know but
we want to be with her
I'm talking with Brian and Theo and
Chris my boys and we haven't seen each
other we're talking this guy goes hey
shot you know he's a promoter and he you
know we know him whatever I don't know
him that well and he comes up and
interrupts
interrupts our entire conversation I've
seen my friend I'm like what's that you
know and I'm like yeah cool and I'm
telling you guys bro let's go play catch
he asked me to play cash I go he's a
beautiful person
there's nothing left that he is just
such a nice guy [ __ ] man it's naive
because he doesn't have kids and also he
was like you know he had two [ __ ]
little boys yeah yeah you figured you're
an athlete
go dirty it's like 38 years old go deep
go to the park oh dude yeah woman meet
you at the park
yeah we're gonna play with the NFL ball
what are we talking about here we got a
Nerf ball
oh yeah my God rollerblade yeah I don't
really and it's not people will listen
to this going oh that's anti-comedy
community no it's it's pro-family dude
the 100 it's Pro family yeah even if I
wasn't a club I missed the Hang though I
miss hanging out at clubs and being
[ __ ] idiots that's the most sad thing
you know what's cool is like the stand
the stand will be like they'll do
something where they'll book like the
same as a friend yeah so like me and
Giannis will pretty much be on the same
thing and then somebody else and then
we'll all sit down and like you're with
your boy so then all of a sudden these
Sports arguments happen and it's good
you sit down sit with Dove and those
guys and it'll be Shane Gillis and be
like that and everybody's there that's a
good that's a good hang yeah and it's
fun we do the seller when you're with
different yeah I do the seller I do the
stand I do you know New York comedy club
and where is the stand that's new right
so that this is the second location it's
bigger it used to be where a Brother's
Jimmy's barbecue is it's on 16th it's
just huge when I realized how long I've
been in L.A I heard uh Gotham isn't
doing a headline or weekends anymore
they're just they're doing spots now is
that right yes it's pandemic they just
do spots down there like we we just
we're making more money just [ __ ] so
they don't that's what I was wondering
about they're not doing it they're not
doing weekends anymore oh [ __ ] I didn't
even know that yeah glad you told me I'm
in New York in a hot second and I
thought I did Gotham that's weird with
Gotham he's like bro yeah like you know
I remember wanting to go to the wanting
to go to the Christmas parties because
that's when you were coming up so like
you're coming up and you're like oh
Caroline's having a Christmas party
everyone's going to be there and you
think it would like do something to be
seen now that now dude when someone's
like well you're going to to yeah yeah
I'm yeah on Christmas so I'm Gonna Leave
yeah yeah that's like festivals too like
festivals are going to change your life
get the [ __ ] out you know what's funny
you said that because I said that
festivals dude here's the thing and a
festival that wants you to stay for
weeks or two it's like listen Montreal
is great going for a day or two you have
a nice show great you go like hey I'm
doing this and and you notice how
they're booking the same people a lot of
the same people and it's like you got to
learn to just be like hey man like I'll
come in like I love my Montreal is a
great and there's a few dude dude uh
skank Fest is incredible when you do
skank Fest everyone it's the only
Festival everybody knows you you go
there and you walk me and Brett Ernst
are walking down the street it's the
only Fest and I've been to Montreal a
lot of times we hear Montreal people
know you too they do the homework
because it's such a big one JFL is like
that I think jfl's like that and uh and
and um and skank first but just like oh
my god dude like they know know you and
where's that at do they do the same
location so no he's doing I think
they're doing Vegas when I the one I did
was last November in Houston but like
the fans it's just different you know
but uh yeah the whole like you have this
thing in your mind where oh I'm gonna be
seen at a holiday party and I might get
and it's like no they want you there to
fill the [ __ ] to be there yeah yeah
they invited you yeah yeah all right
yeah buddy all right real quick though
so Tyson got back to me
and it's the manager of Calvin yeah
Calvin's dude so he's like so first of
all what he's all Calvin's dad is no no
so Calvin does his family comes from
money but Calvin has no access to the
money I'm sure
we just want to like make sure that you
know everyone knows uh so Brian was
technically right he was not brown is
right yeah and Calvin does own a
promotion by the way he fought and at
the same promotion and he he fought it
in the promotion before and he fought
three times just to buy it right so he
actually bought it for fighting three
times for free yeah so he does have
emotions it's called combat zone MMA
they're gonna do something this Friday
so that's cool yeah and I'm it's a
Boston uh I think yeah yeah New England
cartel so Friday go get it and he goes
also this is for you Brian it's a
misconception that he's rich and came up
for money he grew up with a single mom
and they worked super hard to get what
they have and he says you can say that
LOL
I'm not taking anything away from him no
no he's open to Brian's but Brian you're
right you're right about all it was just
like a little detail a bad [ __ ]
and I that's what I found so interesting
about him twice
that's what I find so amazing about him
is that he he didn't come from this
crazy difficult and he's he's a [ __ ]
up you see it he fights like you oh my
God it's like he's broken that's what I
mean like there's not a softness there
of of having access to that when like
you still want to [ __ ] somebody up and
you're a bad dude like that that's
that's enough I haven't been through
some [ __ ] yeah that dude's a bad
[ __ ] but that could also be a
dude that was bullied yeah you know and
he's just like okay when he learns how
to fight yeah he is a great fighter man
yeah really good bro to stand in there
when I watch UFC I'm not joking around
it's like people we've talked to us
before like you text me before dude I
was like what do you got dude yeah yeah
no but when going into an octagon in
front of the world and on pay-per-view
against another man that doesn't that
also wants to [ __ ] you up that's like no
set you ever do stand-up wise will ever
be that where dudes looking at you did
you see what's his name looking at I
knew that's when I knew he was going to
lose though the kid the the co-main
event the kid uh the the oh
um uh Brandon Moreno France this last
one yeah yeah and the way he was looking
at him and stuff and I thought it was it
was like almost too much how the hate
that the other hat guy had but just that
just guys going like this before they
say are you ready and it's like that's
[ __ ]
that's they locked the cage it's a tough
gig yeah you're such a [ __ ] lunatic
that you went from that to this which is
well that's why he wasn't afraid like
that's why he would get in there in his
underwear there's a big difference
between all due respect to 145 pound guy
and then you're fighting a 260 pound guy
let me tell you why when you his head's
the same size as most guys like it's not
this that's it right I was of the head
of a lightweight but but I'm saying but
I'm saying I'm not I'm not like Mark
hunt but I'm saying I mean you get into
those rings with those guys who are 260
pounds they can knock you out with a
[ __ ] jab and if they hit you the
right way you can die or you can get
really [ __ ] up so the point is that
you can get you as a heavyweight you're
getting shut off more than likely if you
make a mistake if you're lightweight you
can make a few mistakes like I should
have zigged one dude you should have
seen the guys
they would pay they would pay these guys
to come in to fight him this is when I
when I was I didn't you know we were
just starting there's not a training
camp dude in his training
Jim called black house which is like me
Leo Machida Anderson Silva these Pro
kickboxers that were six foot nine and
his his coach would say to the pro
kickboxer I'm gonna give you a thousand
dollars if you knock him out okay you'll
get a thousand dollars these guys are
starving now watch I'm talking about six
nine and I'm talking about 250 guys that
have nothing but they also are but they
also can kick and punch professionally
so I thought that Brendan was gonna I
look at him he came in and I went like
this I go I look at Brandon and Brennan
goes Brandon goes you want to be a
fighter huh and he's getting his hands
wrapped and I go
he didn't even warm up really you didn't
even warm up you just get it either
they're just getting ring and I go
They're gonna move around you're gonna
move around no they're not what he was
trying to knock his [ __ ] head off
when I say full speed fight like a full
speed fight it was that and I was just
like I was like this is your life this
is what you have to do you could get so
[ __ ] up you could get so [ __ ] up
doing the wrong and what happened to
that guy Brian you uh you gave him you
get you made him quit you broke him
submit you broke him oh yeah he just he
just broke him he just he goes hey I I
that's when I knew Brandon was like
Brandon goes let's do another round and
the guy goes no
and that was it you just couldn't do it
anymore [ __ ] dude but but I I that's
that's kind of what it takes so then I
would put him up on stage and I go I'm
gonna pretend to be late you get up on
stage and tell a story just tell a story
so he was is that right yeah so he was
doing 1200 people because we we had
Seattle it was 1200 people in the
theater think about you've never done a
stand-up you've never done it I make you
get up but he would just do these weird
breathing exercises and he would just go
it's Fearless
we were doing a stunt this is the one
where I knew there that he was different
we were doing a stunt and what we're
doing is that we were on a horse and we
had to be friends we'd both be on a
horse now a big horse now a horse sir
is here
a horse yeah and we're in the desert so
there's there's rocks and Cactus and
strawberries in the same area where they
shot the Reverend it's a desert
sharp rocks you know the Rocks like this
yeah yeah so we they would have been
funny if we could fall off the horse but
we need stuntmen so I go but we need
some man we need horse guys and it's
very difficult so I was trying to figure
out and Brennan goes well let's just do
it I go what and he goes let's just
we'll just fall off the horse together
and I go what no but you can't fall to
us because you'd fall off and then it's
you have to be a stunt man because
you're gonna let You're Gonna Go from
the horse onto the ground which is six
seven feet yeah and he goes he goes yeah
I know we'll just we'll ride we'll like
rock gallop and then we'll just we'll
fall off the horse and I go and land I
want he goes our backs I don't know and
I go I go I go
that's too dangerous because that's you
can't do that unless you're trained and
you have padding and you know what he
did I swear to God I'm dead serious he
goes you're such a [ __ ] man and I went
I'm not a lot was riding on the show I'm
not a [ __ ]
he is like I don't care like people talk
you want to talk like you can say you're
tough and stuff uh but I've seen him do
these where he's willing to do the
craziest [ __ ] and you're like oh you
played football for that long and you
fought in a cage everything else is easy
yeah everything else is easy his main
sparring partner was a guy named Shane
Carwin who was 285 pounds six foot three
and hit harder than anybody in the
history of the UFC and had the biggest
hands in the UFC have you ever seen what
Shane Carwin looks like for a second
bring him up for a second five days so
that guy was 285 pounds training so he
would pay for my training wow yeah yeah
he beat the [ __ ] out of Brock Lesnar and
until he gassed out
yeah dude [ __ ] that that's what he had
to fight every day [ __ ] dad he had to
wake up and fight that guy yeah oh my
God that's what he had to fight that's
him
that was him but but dude he's six six
two six three and 285 pounds and and I
don't see any fat on him look at Brenda
next to him look at Brandon next to him
that's when he won the ring of fire but
look right there I cornered him holy
look at a young Brandon Shaw with his
[ __ ] sparring head size difference is
crazy too that was when Nate Marquise he
had a real head yeah that was but I said
this before though about Brandon what I
really respect is that to go from that
and have fans and have people know you
and then go into stand up which is hard
and got to get good at it they're
watching you develop from somebody that
doesn't know the how to do the art with
exp because you're just getting into it
to then open Miker to then getting up
there to then middle to then headline
you had an audience for that and that's
what I because we don't have audiences
for that we have we have the hard nights
and we do that but we go home and we
kind of with ourselves you were doing
that in public and that's why I think
it's so dope and I think that that's why
you know people like to hate and stuff
it's like you you know how hard this
[ __ ] put he's he's always always
trying he's always doing the best he can
it's [ __ ] really hard stand up is
[ __ ] really hard he went from
football to fighting to stand up and yet
it's all really putting a [ __ ]
Wrangle [ __ ] alligators next what the
[ __ ] yeah
he's always just wanted to be a comment
I love stand up he's Heroes were Jim
Carrey and yeah Adam Sandler all right
enough about me what do you got Mark
actually uh Paul you go with time
because it's 204 right now yeah well how
much longer like what like your current
events probably like another 15 20 so
man you can Bounce Down
stick around I could do like 10 more if
I could do I gotta go to uh I gotta go
to Beverly Hills I got another one with
this with this girl Justine Moreno or
something
I have a rental but does it make sense
for me to leave now so you guys can take
the time 10 more minutes if you're good
okay yeah
all right so the first one is Conor
McGregor you guys talking about Fighters
so Conor Gregor is going to be in a
movie that's cool on Amazon Prime Rhonda
was supposed to be in this though she's
supposed to be the lead yeah back in the
day
you're supposed to be a two Mark you oh
I I do get the script they did send me
the script for this yes any idea though
that acting like all this [ __ ] start
making me think acting's not that hard
like no no I'm not saying listen I know
that it's it's just but like everyone's
in [ __ ] [ __ ] now like everybody's
doing [ __ ] now you know it's hard but
it's hard to get to like the I think
it's hard to get to an acting level
where you're really like now now hold on
because now is Connor going to be able
to pull off what Jake General and like
carry the movie no no but is Connor
gonna sell tickets to the theater yes
and listen that's why and I'm not saying
I'm not saying he might be the one guy
who can pull it off but here's the thing
Conor McGregor might end up being a
great actor I'm not saying that but like
LeBron James is in like Space Jam and
[ __ ] they're it's kind of almost awful
though but he's acting was so bad oh my
god dude there's there's argument that
Jordan's better you seen Jordan Space
Jam
LeBron is like do you have to read off
the cue card did you not remember the
line really he's like oh my God we have
to beat these guys Connor might surprise
you he might be uh he might imagine an
Oscar right with that speech B
that'd be phenomenal shut your [ __ ]
mouth shut your mouth so check out the
shut your mouth so it's about Jake
Gyllenhaal he's the lead he's going to
be playing a former Swayze remake yeah
it's a remake of Roadhouse yeah but that
was funny like a UFC fighter Brandon got
an audition like I took my ring light
with me on the road to do this then we
look at it it's like eight pages with
all these act outs and you're getting
like eaten by a CR it was like who's
gonna do this for this like you know the
role was substantial but it's like it
was the longest audition like the ACT
outs and stuff so bro
I'm an alligator yeah I I look at that
and then I was just like all right
they're shooting in was that Dominican
Republic how how long you know you if
it'd be a long shot for me to get the
role and then if I do get how long am I
gone from the I just launched this
network so it's like you know Pros we
would have spent the day shooting the
audition you know yeah yeah
all right so I just want to give this
guy props this pizza guy pizza delivery
guy did you guys hear about this or no
he saved five children from a burning
house oh [ __ ] he just got there at the
right time and you can see him he even
like passes out from all the smoke yeah
somebody pulled in to let him know their
house is on fire still see him here
guys come here there's one more kid he
took all four kids out and there's one
more kid so he grabbed the other kid
whoa and you'll see him come look at how
crazy this fire is what pizza company
yeah that's a good question it makes me
want to order their pizza oh damn [ __ ]
oh my God that's the last kid he got all
of them out they saved their parents and
then look at him he's just he's passed
out I can't even breathe
you know I don't know the details of all
if the parents are even there but if the
parents are killed they would say it in
the article but the fact that he saved
these five guys sleeping right I love
that right he was inviting me
that guy deserves a million dollars and
like like so much yeah I mean come on
can we like start a go fun from that no
he does and it's probably killing around
but so yeah he was invited to the Nascar
Brickyard 200 or something like this
yeah
so he's already got plenty of reward for
what he did
quickly rushed into the home leading
four children safety there was a
six-year-old girl trapped Stone side he
found her and jumped from a second yeah
window in his arms using his body to
kill someone dude that wasn't just a
fire
dude that didn't look Inferno that was
calling Inferno that was it did you call
it that was nice
but he's in the NASCAR because his goal
is to become a NASCAR driver
oh so his best backstory in history if
he becomes a NASCAR driver yeah well I
mean oh my God he's the greatest movie
ever how great would that guy's story be
Rudy okay okay I thought you might not
we'll pass that we'll pass this too
let's go to Mark's stuff actually
yeah let's go and Mark stuff give me one
sec
Bradley Cooper hosts 46th birthday how
dare you okay no hold on so Bradley
Cooper is now rumor rumored to be dating
uh Huma who was America and Weiner yeah
that's why I thought that was
interesting
hilarious yeah where is that is he like
he's doing stand-up now dude he's doing
it
with the guardian angels Curtis Silva no
what he's doing a radio show oh he is
yeah that guy's interesting too yeah
dude nothing is serious nothing is real
anymore
you [ __ ] uh you're sending a 15 year
old pictures of your dick and I guess
the babysitter so he's got it together
there but then he got caught again
sending them correct but not to but not
just a normal lady his wife took him
back and then he got busted again she's
all right dude that guy's a [ __ ] mess
you're about Anderson Cooper and uh
what's his name Tucker Carlson doing a
show together no no oh
dude your neck almost broke he just goes
dude hey I'm sewing let me just baby
that would be that might be must watch
TV though that's why I was like I need
something to watch that would be [ __ ]
great they should do [ __ ] like that
that's hilarious Tucker Carlson to me so
like the way he laughs at things I'm
like it's just insane man that's took
her across and just oh you go no I tried
I tried to go longer I thought it was
real too dude Tucker Carlson literally
his entire show which he gets reviews
he's just roasting Biden for an hour
straight oh yeah Julia has right it's
good he's got great writers man because
a lot to work on because
um you know there was a lot of stuff I
didn't like about myself and then when I
had a kid I was like how am I getting a
kid I feel like yeah I'm contagious
anything no no I was like I don't wanna
pass this [ __ ] you know you thought you
could hide something
you know no okay no I have a temper man
you can't hide that like if I was you
know no no we're not hiding at 10 but
the cause of the tempo
well if I could I'm trying to figure out
what is the cause of it I'm trying to
know the cause of it brother oh those
thought that why am I mad why I know you
know what you meant why are you mad who
hurt you
oh [ __ ] oh that yeah but that's what I
just figured out but for years when I
would yell at my phone I thought I hated
technology oh you made a joke
I'm being totally honest nah you silly
dude no you know what it is
you know what's crazy is like Tyson
Tyson is that he's so much smarter than
you think like oh dude like think about
that like he basically was like he knew
like you know he was just like he got
right to the meat and potatoes man the
anger where where'd the anger Bill check
it out he's like I thought it was weird
that was like some therapist [ __ ] like
like that professional doctor [ __ ] that
guy was that guy
yeah
Dr Tyson an hour a week with him he said
that [ __ ] mushrooms changed
everything for him that like literally
changed his name into yeah because he's
like when people say hi I love this guy
do you know this guy my son my son
watches it all the time and his friends
wait Tate or something
asking the guy who walked punch they
were asking why they hit you why they
hit you and I thought they're not
Warriors because if someone punches my
friend I'm gonna go over to whatever the
situation is and start smacking
everybody and we'll find out why later
to your point Fair Point good point see
when you're a world champion kickboxer
you know no but you you don't have to be
a world champion this is [ __ ] Fair
100 ask questions
somebody that [ __ ] punches my friend
you know the biggest thing ever said to
Amber too no he didn't tell me the story
tell so when we were like 20.
Brody's gonna hit on Amber who is and
she just moved out here from Texas we're
quizzing her you know he's trying to you
know date her you know go on a date okay
everybody would like it started and it's
like 10 years ago or more oh no this is
15. okay he just moved to L.A all right
is she like famous workout okay she just
moved here from Texas okay and she's
like I'm not going on a date with you
I'm this is like verbatim a little
misquote and he's like huh she's like
I'm already dating a famous director I'm
gonna be a movie star I wouldn't dare go
on it and Brody's response was because
she had this like this big mole on her
arm that looked very cancerous he's like
well you should do I'm there for the
rest of my life is get to a doctor and
get that more
[Laughter]
that has changed I've been watching you
for a long time actually during this
talk I think it went dark God damn
that horse when it's on the ground but
you know she kind of somebody puts up
his head who hasn't contributed anything
all night he said listen
he's got killed him he says no no this
is a tough one
um nothing contributed I'm running this
business out of my dorm
uh and I'm about to graduate I'm making
about five million totally free cash
flow
and I said I don't hear a problem he
said that's not the problem my fiancee
came to me today
and said
that she's going to leave me and I said
why because I'm not spending any time
with her family I don't have any time on
weekends I can't go out to the soccer
games with her nephews and stuff and I I
didn't I just can't because I'm so busy
and I got to keep my business going I
got to graduate my degree what do I do
right this one is easier to replace
the girlfriend or the business
I mean you gotta ask that question
wow good facts though people say in
college well especially if it's not a
marriage and it's like dating thing like
that's the difference it's not like it's
not like your wife is going you're not
around your kids your actions speak
louder than your words you know what's
more important you you are sorry but the
fact is you're having more fun building
your business he doesn't he doesn't love
that girlfriend yeah like I mean he
might but also he's in college so he's
like maybe he's not very attractive dude
so he's like I want to do things but the
business ties up all my time sometimes
you're ashamed actually sometimes you're
appalled at where your real priorities
are that can happen that is sometimes
you can be like there are people I'm
sorry there are people you're supposed
to love that they could die or they
could you could never see them again not
dive that you could never see them again
you'd be just fine you know what I'm
saying you and I have talked about this
before it's like you got your friends
and then they're it's some of the things
what you'd rather be doing versus what
you're supposed to be rather doing is is
sometimes can be a big [ __ ] secret it
can be very awkward yeah it's like you
know I'd rather be doing yeah I'd rather
be working on this I'd rather be writing
and not be with you is that it fellas
that's it dude thanks for having me man
you're the best version dude it's fun so
fun
um yeah oh by the way if anybody's in uh
I'm leaving tomorrow but if anybody's in
California tomorrow I'm doing the new uh
California Comedy Club the same people
that own New York comedy club on 24th
Street they made a replica Club that's
like a 80 seater in in the Silver Lake
Area I'm going to be running a long set
there tomorrow night at eight o'clock
that's amazing man I didn't know that
yeah yeah silver Lake's not far from
yeah uh I'm gonna be uh I'll be uh sold
Joel's on the 17th of uh September guys
I'm going to London dude for the first
time ever I'm gonna go see the Giants
play the Packers on the ninth in London
but I'm going to be performing at uh uh
Soho 21 or 21 Soho in London you could
check that out I got a one-nighter
Washington DC those are going to sell
out I'm only doing one show uh
Washington DC Improv the 19th of October
and the 20th I'll be at the Philadelphia
punch line and a bunch of new dates are
coming that you can get on um
paulversey.com and check out nocturnal
admissions managed streaming on Netflix
right now it's doing fantastic I'm very
great and you've got a great podcast and
uh yeah do two podcasts one the Versi
effect where I have guests here and
there sometimes by myself and I co-host
one with Bill burkhold anything better
so check all that stuff out I appreciate
you keep pressing brother we love you
man thanks man love you man uh Baltimore
this Thursday Friday Saturday I'm in
Baltimore I know it's a summer but get
your ass out there and then one night
one show only August 26 in Chicago
downtown Chicago Den theater that's one
show only Appleton Wisconsin September
8th through the 10th then Ontario Improv
Ontario California September 15th
through 17th and then I'm back in Boston
baby laugh Boston is September 29th
through October 1st get your tickets at
thickboy.com or fatk az.com B you got a
little bit of a break I got a break but
actually just to this just in August
18th I'll be in Salt Lake City for one
night I'm doing Wise Guys August 18th
tickets just went on sale Wise Guys one
night that's a Thursday then I go to
Bora Bora uh no no I'll be back for that
I go to [ __ ] uh my friend's wedding
Nashville Tennessee Zanies August 26
27th San Jose California Improv
September 1517 Spokane Washington
September 22 23 24 get your tickets
see in a bit that's it kids Baltimore
see this week
Paul love you brother keep crushing it
we're out have fun thanks Paul thank you
guys so much for